[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I was seven years old and my sister
was just five years old we were playing
on top of a bunk bed I was two years
older than my sister at the time I'm two
years older than her now but but at the
time that meant she had to do everything
that I wanted to do and I wanted to play
war so we were up on top of our bunk
beds and on one side of the bunk bed I
had put out all my GI Joe soldiers and
weaponry and on the other side we're all
my sisters Milo's and ponies and ready
for a cavalry charge there are differing
accounts of what actually happened that
afternoon but since my sister is not
here with us today
let me tell you the true story which is
my sister's a little bit on the clumsy
side and somehow without any help or
push from her older brother at all
suddenly Amy disappeared off of the top
of the bunk bed and landed with this
crash on the floor and i nervous Lee
peered over the side of the bed to see
what had befallen my fallen sister and
saw that she landed painfully on her
hands and knees on all fours on the
ground I was nervous because my parents
had charged me with making sure that my
sister and I played as safely and as
quietly as possible and seeing as how I
had accidentally broken amy's arm just
one week before
heroically pushing her out of the way of
an oncoming imaginary sniper bullet for
which I have yet to be thanked I was
trying as hard as I could she didn't
even see it coming I was trying as hard
as I could to be on my best behavior and
I saw my sister's faces wail but pain
and suffering and surprise threatening
to erupt from her mouth and threatening
to wake my parents from the long winters
nap for which they had settled so I did
the only thing my little frantic
seven-year-old brain could think to do
to avert this tragedy if you have
children you've seen this hundreds of
times before I said Amy Amy wait don't
cry don't cry did you see how you landed
no human lands on all fours like that
Amy I think this means you're a unicorn
now that was cheating because there's
nothing in the world my sister would
want more than not to be Amy the hurt
five-year-old little sister but Amy the
special unicorn of course this was an
option that was open to her brain and no
point in the past and you could see on
my poor manipulated sister's face
conflict as their little brain attempted
to devote resources to feeling the pain
and suffering surprise she just
experienced or contemplating her
newfound identity as a unicorn and the
latter one now instead of crying instead
of ceasing our Plains to have waking my
parents with all the negative
consequences that would have been sued
for me and says smile spread across her
face and she scrambled right back up
onto the bunk bed with all the grace of
a baby unicorn
with one broken Lake what we stumbled
across at this tender age which is five
and seven we had no idea at the time was
something that was going to be at the
vanguard of a scientific revolution
occurring two decades later in the way
that we look at the human brain what we
had stumbled across is something called
positive psychology which is the reason
that I'm here today and the reason that
I wake up every morning when I first
started talking about this research
outside of academia out with companies
in school was the very first thing they
said to never do is to start your talk
with a graph the very first thing I
wanted to do is start my talk with a
graph this graph looks boring but this
graph is the reason that I get excited
and wake up every morning and this graph
doesn t mean anything it's faked out of
what we found is
[Music]
[Applause]
if I got this data back studying you
here in the room I would be thrilled
because there's very clearly a trend
that's going on there and that means
that I can get published which is all
that really matters
the fact that there's one weird red dot
that's up above the curve there's one
weird in the room you know who you are I
saw you earlier that's no problem
that's no problem as most of you know
because I can just delete that dot I can
delete that dot because that's clearly a
measurement error and we know that's a
measurement error because it's messing
up my data so one of the very first
things do we teach people in economics
and statistics and business and
psychology courses is how in a
statistically valid way do we eliminate
the weirdos how do we eliminate the
outliers so that we can find the line of
best fit which is fantastic if I'm
trying to find out how many advil the
average person should be taking to but
if I'm interested in potential if I'm
interested in your potential or for
happiness or productivity or energy or
creativity what we're doing is we're
creating the cold to the average with
science if I ask you a question like how
fast can the child learn how to read in
a classroom scientists change the answer
to how fast is the average child learn
how to read in that classroom and then
we tailor the class right towards the
average now if you fall below the
average on this curve then we'll
psychologists get thrilled because that
means you're either depressed or you
have a disorder or hopefully both we're
hoping for both because our business
models if you come into a therapy
session with one problem we want to make
sure you leave knowing you have ten so
you'll keep coming back over and over
again we'll go back into your child have
necessary but eventually what we want to
do is to make you normal again but
normal is merely average and what I
pause it and what positive psychology
posits is if we study what is merely
average we will remain merely average
then instead of deleting those positive
outliers what I intentionally do is come
into a population like this one and says
why why is it the some of you are so
high above the curve in terms of your
intellectual voting athletic ability
musical ability creativity energy levels
your resiliency in the face of challenge
your sense of humor whatever it is
instead of deleting you what I want to
do is study you because maybe we can
glean information not just how to move
people up to the average but how we can
move the entire average up that our
companies and schools worldwide the
reason this graph is important to me is
when I turn on the news it seems like
the majority of the information is not
positive in fact is negative most of us
about murder corruption diseases natural
disasters and very quickly my brain
starts to think that's the accurate
ratio of negative positive in the world
what that's doing is creating something
called the medical school syndrome which
if you know people who have been to
medical school during the first year of
medical training as you read through a
list of all the symptoms and diseases
that could happen suddenly you realize
you have all of them have a
brother-in-law named Bobo which is a
whole nother story
Bobo married Amy the Unicorn Bobo called
me on the phone from Yale Medical School
from Yale Medical School and Bobo said
Sean I have leprosy which even at Yale
is extraordinarily rare but I had no
idea how to console poor Bobo because he
had just gotten over an entire week of
menopause see what we're finding is not
necessarily the reality that shapes us
but the lens to which your brain views
the world that shapes your reality if we
can change the lens not only can we
change your happiness we can change
every single educational and business
outcome at the same time when I applied
to Harvard I applied on it there I
didn't expect to get in and my family
had no money for college when I got a
military scholarship two weeks later
that allowed me to go suddenly something
wasn't even a possibility became a
reality when I went there I assumed
everyone else would see it as a
privilege as well that they'd be excited
to be there even if you're in a
classroom full of people smarter than
you you'd be happy just to be in that
classroom which is what I felt but what
I found there is while some people
experienced that when I graduated after
my four years and then spent the next
eight years living in the dorms with the
students Harvard asked me to wasn't that
guy but what happened
I was an officer of Harvard accounts
those students through the difficult
four years and what I found in my
research in my teaching is that these
students no matter how happy they were
with the original SAS success of getting
into the school two weeks later the
brains were focused not on the privilege
of being there nor on their philosophy
or their physics the brain was focused
on the competition the workload the
hassles the stresses the complaints when
I first went in there I walked into the
freshmen dining hall which is where my
friends from Waco Texas which is where I
grew up I know some of you have heard of
it when I when they come to visit me
they look around they say this freshman
dining hall looks like something out of
Hogwarts some movie Harry Potter which
it does this is Hogwarts a movie Harry
Potter and that's Harvard when they see
this they say Sean why do you waste your
time studying happiness at Harvard
seriously what does a Harvard student
possibly have to be unhappy about
embedded within that question is the key
to understanding the science happiness
because what that question assumes is
there our external world its predictive
of our happiness levels when in reality
if I know everything about your external
world I can only predict ten percent of
your long-term happiness 90 percent of
your long-term our happiness is
predicted not by the external world but
by it through the way your brain
processes the world and if we change it
if we change our formula for happiness
and success what we can do is change the
way that we can then affect reality what
we found is that only 25% of job
successes are predicted by IQ
seventy-five percent of job successes
are predicted by your optimism levels
your social support and your abilities
see stress as a challenge instead of as
a threat I talked to a boarding school
up in New England probably the most
prestigious boarding school and they
said we already know that so every year
instead of just teaching our students we
also have a Wellness Week and we're so
excited Monday night we have the world's
leading expert coming in to speak about
adolescent depression Tuesday night is
school violence and bullying Wednesday
night Wednesday nights eating disorders
thirst united's illicit drug user Friday
night we're trying to decide between
risky sex or happiness
I said that's most people's Friday
nights
[Music]
which I'm glad you liked but they did
not like that at all silence on the
phone and into the silence I said I'd be
happy to speak at your school but just
you know that's not a Wellness week
that's the sickness week what you've
done is you've outlined all the negative
things that can happen but not talked
about the positive the absence of
disease is not health here's how we get
to health we need to reverse the formula
for happiness and success in the past
three years I've traveled to 45
different countries working with schools
and companies in the midst of an
economic downturn and what I found is
the most companies and schools follow a
formula for success which is this if I
work harder I'll be more successful and
if I'm more successful then I'll be
happier that undergirds most of our
parenting styles are managing style is
the way that we motivate our behavior
and the problem is it's scientifically
broken and backwards for two reasons
first every time your brain has a
success you just change the goalposts of
what success look like you got good
grades now you have to get better grades
gone to a good school and after you get
better school you got a good job now you
have to get a better job you hit your
sales target we're gonna change your
sales target and if happiness is on the
opposite side of success your brain
never gets there what we've done is we
push happiness over the cognitive
horizon as a society and that's because
we think we have to be successful
successful then we'll be happier but the
real problem is our brains work in the
opposite order if you can raise
somebody's level of positivity in the
present then their brain experiences
what we now call a happiness advantage
which is your brain and positive
performs significantly better than does
a negative neutral stress your
intelligence Rises your creativity Rises
your energy levels rise in fact what we
found is that every single business
outcome improves your brain and positive
is 31 percent more productive Mendut
your brain and negative neutral stress
you're 37% better at sales
doctors are 19% faster more accurate at
coming up with the correct diagnosis
when positive instead of negative
neutral stress which means we can
reverse the formula if we can find a way
becoming positive in the present then
our brains work even more successfully
as we're able to work harder faster and
more intelligently what we need to be
able to do is to reverse this formula so
we can start to see what our brains are
actually capable of because dopamine
which floods into your system when
you're positive has two functions not
only does it make you happier it turns
on all the learning centers in your
brain allowing you to adapt to the world
in a different way we've found that
there are ways you can train your brain
to be able to come more positive in just
a two minute span of time done for 21
days in row
we can actually rewire your brain
allowing your brain to actually work
more optimistically and more
successfully we've done these things in
research now in every single company
that I've worked with getting them to
write down three new things that they're
grateful for for 21 days in a row three
new things each day and at the end of
that their brain starts to retain a
pattern of scanning the world not for
the negative but for the positive first
journaling about one positive experience
you've had over the past 24 hours allows
your brain to relive it exercise teaches
your brain your behavior matters we find
that meditation allows your brain to get
over the cultural ADHD that we've been
creating by trying to do multiple tasks
at once and allows our brains to focus
on the task at hand
and finally random acts of kindness or
conscious acts of kindness we get people
when they open up their inbox to write
one positive email praising or thanking
somebody in their social support network
and by doing these activities and by
training your brain just like we trained
our bodies what we found is we could
reverse the formula for happiness and
success and in doing so now let create
ripples of positivity but create a real
revolution thank you very much
[Applause]